are the covid hot spots cooling or not
two weeks ago darlington had one of the
highest rates in the country
according to the official government
stats cases have since
tumbled more than halved but confusingly
new figures from the office for national
statistics show the infection rate here
and
elsewhere is still rising particularly
in the young
if so the third wave is far from over
it's scary quite scary times to be
honest because we think we're actually
getting back to normal and it's not
it's really not for me right now my
priority is getting back to some kind of
normality
i may be worried i mean it hasn't
happened to any of them but it's a bit
worried in case it happens
the new data from the office for
national statistics covers the week up
to the 24th of july
over that period the daily dashboard
showed reported cases across england
fell by a third but the ons a random
survey that tests people whether or not
they got symptoms
shows the number infected with the virus
increased by more than 15 percent
it estimates that more than 856 000
people
had covered in that week so there's a
conflict in the data
now it's possible that the ons figures
lag slightly behind the official
dashboard stats
because it counts people who are
infected rather than
just new infections but a new document
released by
government scientists warns lack of
school testing now that the holidays
have started
may result in some cases being missed
there's been a 14
drop in the number of tests being done
across the uk
but secondary school aged children are
among the most likely to be infected
with more than three percent carrying
the virus according to the ons
that's almost as high as the rate in six
formers and young adults up to the age
of 24
and one scientist thinks the rise of the
delta variant may also be part of the
story
this may well be a consequence of the
delta variant we don't know but you're
more likely to have cold-like symptoms
now
than with previous waves of infection so
people won't be reporting those or even
testing themselves as a consequence of
thinking well
i know this is not a a classical coveted
symptom so
i think i think a number of things have
come together actually which make the
daily
figures rather suspect the rollback of
the last legal coed measures last week
has yet to affect the data
if people are now less cautious cases
could bounce
as the third wave once again picks up
speed
thomas more sky news